we're gonna start talking football right
now and also society American society as
a whole because that's what Kenny Stills
is is about has been about he is the
Walter Payton Man of the Year nominee of
the Miami Dolphins fresh off of a tour
and that you sir said on your Twitter
feed at K stills with the AIA beliefs
lowercase correct I noticed that to see
the work being done in the fight for
equality and social justice good to see
you Kenny Stills here on the show in
studio yes sir thank you so why did you
take this tour what was it's all about
here um you know when the off season
came start a little bit early for us
obviously since we didn't make the
playoffs I wanted to find a way to
continue to kind of do the work that
I've been doing in the local community
there in Miami and I love traveling I
love being on the road so I rented an RV
and thought let's see some of the work
that you know some of the grassroots
organizations are doing around the
country and particularly in the south
and you started in Miami then you went
to the the state capitol of Tallahassee
first up and you met with dream
defenders to protest for fair treatment
of incarcerated individuals is that does
that go straight to the heart of why you
were protesting during the national
anthem this year no not directly to the
to the heart of but you know I see
myself as somebody that is about human
rights you know and and for people are
not being treated fair it's not right
and so I'd have the opportunity to go up
there and really be on the front lines
in protest and and try and start
conversation was an opportunity that I
couldn't pass up okay and so what what
did you glean during this trip where you
went to the MLK Center in Atlanta here
in Los Angeles where you met dr. John
Carlos as well what did you what did you
learn on this trip here Kenny um I
learned a lot honestly for me it was
really about educating myself about the
his the history of the civil rights
movement connecting with young adults
young males and trying to mentor and
show them that people care about them
and understand that you know I grew up
in some in similar situations and that I
want to do everything I can
and use my platform to help you know
elevate their voices because you know
sometimes they feel like they're not
being heard or change isn't coming their
way
mm-hm and did you did you leave more
hopeful than when you got on that RV at
all or I mean how did you come through
this ya know to be honest it's very
there's a lot of negativity you know in
the world and we hear a lot of
negativity you know through our social
media channels so it was really special
for me to connect with a lot of these
organizations and these people that have
sacrificed themselves and dedicate
themselves to to helping others you know
and so just connecting with like-minded
people positive people and see the work
that they're doing it really like warmed
my heart and and uplifted my spirit yeah
Kenny Stills here on the Rich Eisen show
let's walk through some other places
that you went to you you you went over
the Edmund Pettus Bridge yeah what were
you thinking when you did that in soma
unbelievable the feeling I had just
walking across there a really emotional
person so I was fighting back tears
pretty much the whole time and being
able to just picture and imagine what it
was like for them to march across that
bridge and ya know it just was special
to me to be there and see that and and
and know that the history that that's
there and the Medgar Evers house you
went to in Jackson Mississippi well he
was assassinated yep and then did you go
to the the the hotel the motel in
Memphis where Martin Luther King yes
Rights Museum I think and yes that that
was probably the most powerful or one of
the most powerful experiences that I
thought what were you feeling I mean you
you go into different rooms throughout
the museum lead leading up to where he
was assassinated and just every room I
went into I just was filled with so much
emotion I was fighting back tears in
every room that I was in just angry and
I'm sad disappointed her combination of
all these feelings and then you get to
the to the room where where he's
assassinated and you see the ledge that
he was at and kind of the angle from
where the shooter was
and I just broke down you know and I
couldn't hold back the tears anymore I
couldn't hold back the way that I was
feeling and I was kind of embarrassed
you know because there's a lot of other
people in the museum you know doing
their thing and paying their respects
and I just I couldn't help myself you
know just being there in that moment and
understanding and seeing all the work
and sacrifice everyone has made
throughout the civil rights movement
really just touch mark Kenny Stills here
on the Rich Eisen show and then in New
Orleans you hooked up with the your
rights camp run by none other than Colin
Kaepernick yeah what's what what spirits
is Colin Kaepernick in right now uh-huh
he's in great spirits the know your
rights camp is by far the most
impressive thing that I've ever been a
part of why is that just the work that
they're doing
you know educating I think there was
over 400 kids there educating them on
their African history you know we get
into these breakout groups and they're
learning about technology and they're
learning about holistic health and
they're learning about finance and so
they're leaving this camp with these
tools and and then also you know have an
African ancestry kit you know in their
bags and leave them with a pair of shoes
and just like all these different tools
and and the way that they run the camp
is it's very family or like oriented and
the volunteers are so invested and the
teachers and everyone that's there it's
just it's a very special I think like
the happiest I've ever been was the day
after like the night after the camp was
over and we all spent time together I
was I was just on a high does he want to
play football still oh yeah yeah I know
we tax - the other day about you know
throwing this offseason and doing things
together and he's ready to play does he
think he's gonna play honestly um I
don't I don't have any club I would
think that he thinks he's gonna play I
don't see why not you know there's a lot
of teams I need quarterbacks he's a
great player and honestly that the
controversy that we have going on with
the national anthem and what the owners
are saying and how they feel about it
we've we've we've got to move past like
this this false narrative that they've
made and really just own up to the
mistakes that we have you know as
and not getting a ahead of this
conversation and not pushing the
narrative in the right direction and and
allowing our guys to speak up and speak
out the way the NBA does and embracing
that and and embracing that as part of
our culture on our league but the NBA
does not say what they're saying players
are not saying what they're saying
during the national anthem with a
symbolic act right and the owner of the
Miami Dolphins wasn't even Ross it says
that that he's concerned about it's an
ineffective tactic that alienates more
people than it end lists yeah which is
kind of the heart of what what's you and
I are talking about right now right so
do you feel that it's still an effective
tactic to try and get across the points
that you're trying to get across about
society Kenny Stills yes I do
taking a knee has always been an a way
for us to bring eyes to issues that
people might not understand or might not
experience and to start that
conversation and so the people that are
willing and open to have this
conversation and they hear and they
educate themselves and they hear the
statistics about the things that are
going on in our country it's very easy
for them to understand and be empathetic
and and to kind of jump I guess to the
other side of the fence if you will and
we're not we're not disrespecting
anybody no one's against the military no
one's against the police we just want
people to be held accountable for their
actions and that's that's not happening
and so if you're willing to have a
conversation they're taking anything is
it's not a big deal if you're not then I
see why it why it bothers you
cuz tharok I have met some people who
would love to have this conversation but
still at their core believe that there's
a disrespecting of the national anthem
that's going on right now right have you
or any other players in the NFL talked
about having a different forum for this
moving forward you know I think players
understand that the league is gonna try
and do something different regarding
the national anthem next year so you
know I've definitely thought about what
I'm going to do and I think it's
something we'll speak about the players
association meetings this weekend but
you know the people that I've talked to
that disagree with what I'm doing
you know don't really understand one or
haven't really tried to really deep dig
deep into the situation and
understanding that the reason why Colin
and a lot of players were taking a knee
beef is because of the conversation that
he had you know asking him to go from
sitting to kneeling and you know so I
think it's just like I said being being
open to having that conversation and
knowing that you know just because you
feel some way about something somebody
else feels a different way and that
that's all right in this country Kenny
Stills here from the Miami Dolphins have
you spoken to your team's owner Stephen
Ross I haven't about his comments what
do you think about his comments you know
obviously you know I was I wasn't too
thrilled with his comments but you know
III understand I guess where he's coming
from and you know I I just was a little
bit frustrated with the fact that he's
you know can say that because the
president says something is a certain
way that's that's the final say or the
way that he's you know kind of made his
followers think that it's about
something else that it's the final say
and that's just frustrating to me
because that's not that's not right
that's not true you know just because
somebody says it's something something
is a certain way that's not how it is
and so how have your conversations in
the past with Stephen Ross on this
subject gone have you had any yeah no
we've had plenty of conversations all
the players that were participating in
and and the protests have I've had many
conversations with him and I think you
know he's just obviously worried about
where the where the narrative is going
and you know understands that the league
didn't really do a good job of of
controlling the narrative from the very
beginning and so now it's it's been kind
of changed and into something that it's
not but you do understand that there are
still some people that won't even listen
to your message because they can't get
past the fact that somebody's kneeling
during the national and
right Dan and then let's I understand
that I grew up in Oceanside California
right by the military base my Pop Warner
coach is one of the most influential
people in my life he was in the military
served in the military for 20-plus years
and before I decided to take a knee I
called them I had before the game and I
told them hey this is what we're
thinking about doing and and I wasn't
really like educated and anything really
I just knew this feeling that I had in
my gut and I told him about it and you
know he asked me straight up you know
III would hope that you would not take a
stance during the game tomorrow and you
know I slept on it and I prayed on it
and the next morning I knew I wasn't
gonna be able to live with myself if I
didn't get involved and this was my way
of getting involved in at the end of the
day it's a peaceful protest you know if
if it really really bothers you that
much that we're taking a knee peacefully
silently and this that's a sign of
respect to us taking a knee I mean I'm
sorry I'm sorry that you feel that way
but let's let's let's have a
conversation I'm easy to contact through
social media on the phone like we can
have a conversation about it and you
know accept our differences I do you
have a relationship with your Pop Warner
coach okay you guys are cool yeah okay
and what is your plan for next year do
you have one as far as the protest go
sir um you know if like I said I think
that the league isn't gonna allow us to
be out there during the national anthem
and so I'm working on you know figuring
out a way to still get my message out
there and and do something positive and
still you know promote social justice
issues all right Kenny I'd love to take
a break come back hit you on the topic
of the day about the combine your
combined experience obviously we'll talk
some football with the Miami Dolphins
with your quarterback coming back and
Jarvis Landry perhaps walking out the
door and all that okay great Kenny
Stills here on the Rich Eisen show we
are back with the Walter Payton Man of
the Year nominee from the Miami Dolphins
and guy entering his fifth year in the
National Football League out of Oklahoma
maybe we'll talk a little Baker Mayfield
to we come back with Kenny Stills and
the Miami Dolphins here on the
Richardson show
come back to the Rich Eisen show Kenny
Stills is here from the Miami Dolphins
we just had a really interesting deep
conversation about your tour down
throughout the deep south now I want to
hit on the top story in the NFL today
which is darius Geiss of LSU saying that
he was asked questions that I think
they're two beyond the pale in the
interview room whether he liked men or
whether his mom was from a profession of
ill repute I'm wondering what you think
of that story Kenny yeah honestly I
think that those questions are uncalled
for
I see what you're talking about earlier
just you know it's it's other guy that
called them basically saying that it's a
way to see if you can get a rise out of
somebody or get a reaction out of them
but it's it's unnecessary and you know I
dealt with you know similar questions
when I was going through the process as
well say so you say it again you you
were you were you had the same question
yeah yeah there's a question yeah there
was a picture of me in a dress from when
I was in college that made some
headlines and you know I grew up with
with three sisters so older sisters so
they put me in girls clothing all the
time so I'm very comfortable putting on
women's clothing it's not like it an
issue to me so I did it as a joke and so
when I get into the interview room they
asked me like hey what's this
you know I are we're gonna have an issue
with you in our locker room like what
what does this mean why are you doing
this and you know it's like I said I
think it's uncalled for but also I want
it they think it's it's they want to see
how guys are gonna react do you remember
which team asked you that question
no we're multiple teams who asked you
that yeah multiple teams had the picture
I had the photograph yeah well obviously
they have everything on that's ever been
said about you or ever been posted about
you or anything like that how did you
react in the interview room I told him
exactly what I told you the girl that I
was dating at a time at the time we went
to a wedding and after I just was joking
around and put it on and she took a
picture and you know I don't think she
realized like out of her friends from
the opposite school or following her on
Twitter and stuff and so like a couple
days later she must have put it on like
as a joke like laughing and the kids
from Oklahoma State picked it up and so
though you know they it became viral in
the Internet
they're making posters of it and like
everyone had it in the stands and they
were using it to try and get me off my
game but for me it was just a joke you
know like I said I've got older sisters
they dressed me as a as a little girl
all the time so let me ask you this cuz
2013 when you were drafted that was the
year Michael Sam was at the combine as
well so do you think that that might
have been on the brain of the a talent
evaluation community because of that or
do you think that this is an issue of
what the NFL that they have that they're
constantly asking these questions
potentially the prospects Kenny a little
bit of both a little bit of both like I
said I don't think your sexual
orientation has anything to do with you
as a player whatever but it's just one
of those things that you know in the
interview process the NFL asks a lot of
questions and they want to see how
you're gonna react or what your answer
is and so that's just one of the things
that they kind of prepares for and in
the pre-interview process what else were
you asked anything outlandish you know
how to do i when I was a freshman and so
they asked about was the right flag that
was that you had on your so we talked
about that that was really it you know I
feel like for the most part and in
college I had a good time I did my job I
played well and you know they they red
flagged me for the dress picture and the
DUI thing and and obviously I've done a
good job of showing them that you know I
don't have any issues do you think a
team that it asked this of guys or
whichever team asked this of you should
be disciplined um I don't know it's hard
to say that's hard to say um I really
have to think about that a little bit
more okay Kenny Stills here on the Rich
Eisen show and in terms of you know your
alma mater sending a kid to the combine
Baker Mayfield his questions in the
interview room were essentially about
his cockiness and his bravado maybe and
his easily triggered personalities we
saw with Kansas this year yeah refusing
to shake his hand what do you think
about Baker Mayfield's readiness to play
at the next level best you can tell I
mean I think he's gonna be an asset to
whatever team picks him up and that
he'll fight for an opportunity to be a
starting quarterback by
Game one of the season mm-hmm okay so
you would you let's just say dolphins
are sitting there would you I'm very
comfortable with the quarterback that we
have okay but like I said I think
wherever that he wherever he goes he's
gonna go up and put a fight put up a
fight and and and try and be the starter
okay
how is tan ale he's doing best you can
tell he's doing great okay um he's
coming back he's ready to go
hasn't missed a beat the kid works works
his tail off and that's someone that's
inspiring to the team and we're all
excited to have him back in the huddle
okay and how do you believe Kenny Stills
in your heart of hearts you look up week
one and you look in the huddle and
there's Jarvis Landry in your huddle
what do you think do I believe week one
that he's that he's in the huddle yes
sir um honestly I don't know I
understand that you know this is a
business and you know that he's got to
do what's what's the best for him the
Dolphins got to do what's best you know
for the team and the cap and all that
and so I don't know but you know I
signed back with the Miami Dolphins to
play with drivers Landry to pay to play
with Devante Parker to play with Ryan
Tannehill um I thought that we could
have a three-headed monster and as a
receiving corps and be you know the best
even core in the league and so that's
what I signed back for and and you know
that's what I hope to have so well the
conversation that people have about
Jarvis Landry is they look at his
average yard per catch and you removed
the Yaak and he's not somebody who takes
the top of the defense off and thus he's
not really a top receiver in this
National Football League you play with
him how good is he uh Jarvis is one of
the best receivers I ever played with as
far as route running knowing the
defense's coverages his hands and the
guys gonna make people miss and break
tackles so Isaac like I said about Baker
he's gonna be an asset wherever he goes
to and you know hopefully it's what the
Dolphins but if it's not like I said I
understand the business portion of okay
and how good is Kenyan Drake gonna be we
talked about him in the television only
segment he opened my eyes after the jury
trade I thought like most people that
you guys were just you know already just
folding up tenth maybe next year etc etc
yeah oh my gosh did you see in practice
I guess what none of us knew essentially
no we knew and
my ten embalming those guys upstairs
knew what they were doing drafting him
you know he's gonna be as good as he
wants to be and I think that about a lot
of guys in the NFL if you put the time
in in the offseason you dedicate
yourself to becoming a better player to
understanding the game to know in the
offense you can be as good as you want
to and I see that in Kenyan as well so
what is the what do you want people to
know about NFL players that you think
you're just judged you're judged as a by
your cover okay you're we don't see your
face okay you're the only you're the
you're the only athlete on a stage in
the United States of America most of the
time and your face is covered we hardly
ever see it I know hockey players have
helmets on but we can really see their
face a little bit more your faces are
covered you know unless you're one of
maybe 10 15 players
there's no commercials that you're doing
and you as a player are known for
maybe being anti-american anti-military
based on what you're trying to achieve
for quality in this country what do you
want people to know that they don't know
potentially you know I want people to to
know and understand that you know not
everyone is born into the same situation
and everyone is born into you know
having you know both parents or a great
family and we don't have to let like the
the places that were born into like
dictate our outcome but we also have to
understand that there are people that
are in this country that are just trying
to survive and they're not necessarily
criminals are just trying to make ends
meet or survive and live for the next
day and so we've got to do a better job
of calling on our government officials
our community leaders to to you know
close this this wage gap or close the
poverty gap and do a better job of
helping each other and bring each other
up
so you're not just gonna shut up and
carry the ball no no definitely not and
it's not something that's just during
the national anthem it's not something
that's for last year or whatever like
this is something that I'm committed to
is something that I feel
wholeheartedly about deep down inside
and so I think you know it's in your
best interest to to you know get on that
train and being about it clearly is you
could anybody just takes a look at your
Twitter feed can tell at at K stills on
Twitter but in terms of just just to
wrap it up knowing who football players
are right I mean you you your answer was
about what you're trying to cast a
spotlight on about our society our
country professional football player
that you might be just again judged by
the cover yeah no I think just people
understanding that we're just humans a
lot of us you know a lot of people want
I think a lot of guys are different guys
aspire to be famous or to being
well-known or whatever and I grew up in
Oceanside California I saw a junior sail
I saw what he was to the people of
Oceanside the people of San Diego and
that was something that I admired and
inspired to be I think he was very
reachable as far as like you know he was
holding beach workouts and kids knew who
he was they could shake his hand they
they knew who he was as a man and that's
something that I had I aspire to be you
know just a regular person and you know
that's that's you can learn about me
from this conversation from following me
and being around me but we're all
different you know some guys aspire to
be famous and rich and all that type of
stuff and then there's other guys like
me that are just I just want to be
regular human beings gonna end last
question for you Kenny Stills do you
hear my footsteps after what you just
saw yes not worried about your footsteps
at all but I like your cleats I see your
cleats back here your forms gotten a lot
better over time if you really like
honestly seriously I can get you on some
forty training stuff I ran off pretty
fast forty what get you right
what would you run so I have four to
eight unofficial and then I think I was
like four thirty five or four three
eight but I'll get your start right okay
I'll get you right are you serious
because I will take this I guess we can
get your start going right now
I remember my start and everything being
right right right now right now you have
to train you know that right we'll get
you a pair of shoes I like day before
stretching is this a year long
dedication we need about what do you
what do you what do you need for months
cuz I think it's one of the sleds I got
to get you on the parishes well let you
know you're not talking about winter
vacation no no okay sleds parachutes and
then we get your start right okay arms
pumping the right way cuz that's where
you get you so I run to the 2019 combine
whenever the heck that is so let's just
say early March we can walk it back what
like week week 8 NF L season okay
I can start with your face time okay get
you right on your training and then
after the season's over we'll meet up
and then we can do the final stills you
were you were hired cool okay no fee
just just a flight on the Sleep Number
bed okay last one those plus one that's
my kind of guy alright I'm in I mean I
appreciate you offering that cuz you
know it goes for a good cause st. Jude
Children's Research Hospital
okay Kenny Stills love having you here
don't be strangers okay cuz I'm coming
cool I'm calling play see what I'm
saying
Kenny Stills here eight four four two oh
four rich number to dial when we come
back in sixty Seconds the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience